hey hey lisa hi hey so i have to admit i
started watching season two
right before bed last night and i stayed
up till 4am finishing it it was so good
oh whoa thank you so much yeah no it's
uh
it's just everything that i wanted and
how i wanted everything to wrap up
um you know we definitely saw may
hitting their breaking point at the end
of season one
so how would you describe may's journey
in season two
when we start season two a lot of those
external
pressures have been stripped away like
like the sort of
intense threat of drug relapses you know
that's happened
and so and also the the stress of george
being in the closet that's also gone so
i think it sort of forces those two
central characters to
look more deeply at themselves and and
figure out
whether they're ready for each other and
how they're going to function this
individual's
world so that's kind of what's going on
yeah did your experience you know
obviously this show is largely based on
uh your own experiences was filming
season one different than filming season
two for you
so different yeah yeah experiences were
so different from i don't know
i think everything was such an unknown
for season one i was so
nervous and stressed and i like in
between takes i was always running
over to the monitor and like i just
couldn't and i think for season two i
released a bit
more control and i was a little more
more present
i was able to chat more just relax
yeah that's awesome uh lisa i am
obsessed with your character on this
show
i love you so much um obviously this is
a very
challenging relationship um you know
between these two characters how would
you say that the relationship evolves
this season
um well i think how it evolves is
i mean i think it takes a turn for the
worse
until you know the end because
uh yeah there's this lack of trust and
this
underlying resentment that you had to be
such a
difficult child you had to make me worry
about you when i could have been doing
other things for myself
that's kind of how i saw it
yeah what do you love about this show oh
sorry no mate go
i just feel like they don't have to get
to know each other as adults like
as as individuals and i guess we all
kind of have to do that in our
20s and 30s with our parents just except
okay
we're both adults how are we going to
have a sort of friendship and
yeah it is weird though i admit because
i've gone through that i'm in my 30s and
it is really interesting when you don't
look at your
parents like parents anymore they're
just people
yeah so i feel like i could really
relate to that um okay so lisa let's
talk about your character in the awkward
skype calls uh the mandatory house
supervision
um and the spying on may would you say
that your parenting style in real life
at all is similar to this well
um at all sure but not at all
no that's good that's good but you would
say you're protective
what yes you you're very protective like
on a scale of one to ten you're like
uber protective
mom internally yes i
try as hard as i can not to deliver it
to my son but i do yeah that's okay
um well i do obviously i'm sure you're
getting this all today but when it comes
to the friends reunion i didn't even
realize i needed a duet between
you uh and lady gaga when it comes to
smelly cat
what was i'm just so happy it's in my
life now what was that moment like for
you
um fantastic and
the thrill of hearing lady gaga's voice
just sitting on the couch i forget that
it was smelly cat but just being to sit
next to lady gaga and she's
belting anything was thrilling how's
that yeah
really and then to hear yeah and then to
hear that your character meant so much
to her
that's awesome right yeah that was
yeah i i think i wish i had said it
louder
you know i'm not gonna cry um and wanted
to hug but that was the
height of covet in la when when we did
that
we had to do that earlier so yeah i wish
it were a little
warmer on my part yeah no i heard you
say that
did you watch the reunion yeah i just
watched it on
sunday night and cried a lot and
yeah i yeah i i don't know if you just
said it you didn't realize how much you
needed it i felt like that was like oh
my god
yeah it was really moving and i think
what was nice was seeing how much
you guys all seem to still like the show
and love it the way the fans do because
we all still love it
so so nice that you guys were so happy
to be there and just had positive
memories and yeah well congratulations
on season two
uh honestly the fans because this show
is so well loved by so many people
especially after season one um so i'm
really excited to see season two thanks
so much guys
thank you
you